the Herrera family has successfully sold
luxury cars in Argentina through crisis
after economic crisis but recently even
their sales figures have hit a serious
slump last year a dealer like this used
to sail about one car per day it was
like 365 cars a year right now as a
business like this
luckily they sell seven cars a month
until recently Buenos Aires residents
treated car dealerships like this one as
virtual currency exchanges it was a way
to buy dollars with four wheels
restrictions on dollar purchases and
rapidly rising inflation meant consumers
needed new spots to safely park their
pesos if you have pesos on on on your
hands you're losing money every month
because of the inflation so the way to
preserve that money is to buy perhaps a
luxury car 2013 car sales consequently
topped a record million units around a
tenth of those were luxury vehicles
buying cars became an asset class
exactly exactly it was a clear sign that
for Prive sector it was a way of getting
an asset that we served its value after
a correction in exchange rate a new
government tax at the start of this year
put an end to that car sales boom and
cause dealerships like this one in
Buenos Aires to close its doors for good
the new tax applied a 50% duty to cars
costing more than twenty six and a half
thousand dollars but just before that
came into effect one businessman spent
thirty five thousand dollars on this
Mercedes CL 250 he never drove it
leaving it untouched for the Herrera's
to sell on consignment seven months
later their asking price is eighty five
thousand dollars and it's not just the
luxury market that's backfiring auto
sales right across the board have
dropped 40 percent from eighty eight and
a half thousand in June last year to 53
thousand twelve months later the
government does not think economic
problems in a systemic way and they
don't realize what the what are the
consequences of
their short time decision that they make
this patchwork approached economic
policy has forced businesses here to
apply the brakes while they wait to find
out what's around the next corner